often my litmus test for someone who's
negative is and I look at where they are
and usually see the people that are
positive are in a good spot and so that
for me because I experience a lot of
people who would brag and you're right
it's always in a way that's done and
then you finally become aware after many
years of seeing oh but I see why because
the ones that are affirming they're
usually not in a bad situation and so
that's how I don't know if that's work
for you but that's how I've been able to
see who's usually I know Julia Cameron
called it a poisonous playmate oh yeah
and I love that term oh oh yes that's a
very good one and in the aware of the
soul leaders chapter of the book I talk
about that you have these people in your
life and they're your girlfriends or
your guy friends or whatever and you
notice you'll always notice that when
you go and you meet for drinks or
whatever you're going to so how are you
doing you know she says to you or he
says to you and you say two sentences
and before you know it you've spent 15
minutes talking about her or him
they don't really engage in to find out
what's happening with you for real they
open with that but then it all comes
back to them and you know identify those
people in your lives and if you think
that they're a valuable person and you
would like to keep them talk to them
about this lopsided relationship as far
as your communication goes and if they
want to make an effort to change
wonderful itness not minimize your
experience with them because you don't
want to hang out with anybody who leaves
you feeling worse than when you got
there to meet them you know right yeah
and I think it's a real skill to know
who those people are and sometimes if
you're saying to yourself well you know
what I still enjoy their company I'm
going to know that that's how the
relationship is I'm going to keep
anything that's good sometimes to myself
because I don't want it to be shot over
completely
it could be contained it you know if
they don't get bad on me I don't want
that stuff keeps out yourself I'm
keeping my good to me right now because
you're my your
my martini friends for today or what I'm
doing today I'm not sharing my precious
things with you because they're not
they're not valued they're not treated
with regard right people place with some
things yeah I just kind of know okay
you're yeah you're my martini friend or
coffee from whatever it is it and and
I'm going to minimize anything that I
don't want to have tainted and what do
you think that is in this town because
people say they want other people to do
well and I think there are people that
do encourage that for people and then
there's others that don't and how do you
know kind of when to keep good news to
yourself and I know that sounds really
negative and I don't really know it
doesn't mean you you you share the good
news with the people that you trust and
that love you and that are rooting for
you who are the same people who when you
have a bad day they and you say oh just
didn't work or whatever it is they go
they commiserate with you for a minute
and they kick in the house and say all
right on to the next oh yeah that must
have been disappointing but you know
there's tomorrow you didn't get it
listen nobody gets your job you get your
job nobody gets your job if you didn't
get the job
guess what but in your jobs you know
don't you can you get don't go around
saying you lost an audition
you cannot lose anything you never had
the only time you can lose something is
if you got hired for the job and got
fired you know so the the I'm sorry did
I wander far a few oh no no no why I
like that I like that so let's suppose
that oh well she got it over me she took
it over me no doesn't exist no okay no
it was her job it wasn't your job and if
you did if you screwed up in the room
and you didn't do your work your
preparatory work before your audition or
your story pitch or whatever it was and
you think you could have done better
than just do your do your due diligence
more thoroughly the next time you have a
chance but it isn't if you went in and
for any of these interviews and this
goes for any business you know this
really goes for any business if you did
your best in that room then you you went
to work whether you booked the job or
not
you or you went to work
I just worked today I walked in I did
the audition that I wanted to do I
pleased myself I did I gave it the
values I wanted it to have I can't do
any more than that and you get again
this applies to everything you in this
business and many others you have no
control over why you do or do not get
something all through my career at all
ages in my career I have been too tall
too short too fat too thin too pretty
not pretty enough too old or too young
you know I mean it did just come up with
anything if it's not you if you're not
the one that they hire well she wasn't
quite this or she wasn't quite that or
she's you know or he or whatever so it
just let it go because you can't you
only have control over what you do in
that room that's all you have control
over and then you have to go and have
fun right after that audition that's
another thing that I advise people to do
is have somewhere fun to go or someone
fun to meet after every audition because
that's your reward you should reward
yourself you went to work you went to
work
you